[Music]
innovation doesn't happen on its own
it needs leaders to drive it
the innovation leadership bootcamp is
not just your regular
online program it is immersive and it is
intense you are going to interact with
people from all around the world
learn from the best experts and receive
personalized feedback from amazing
entrepreneurs
our coaches are mit alumni who are
entrepreneurs
executives or investors they understand
what it takes to generate an innovation
and to design a venture
to support it they're going to be able
to push you
past what you thought was possible you
will get
wide exposure to mit faculty who are
pushing the frontiers in different
fields
like many mit courses the bootcamp is
a living lab where we're asking you to
identify important problems produce your
own data
and create an effective solution
the bootcamp is a team project-based
learning experience so
you will collaborate with people from
extremely diverse backgrounds
people who push you to look at the world
differently and
over the course of those 10 weeks you
will build a venture with
your team members we really embrace real
world challenges and real big
problems you will see ventures targeting
sustainability
education economic inclusion it's about
whether you can design a solution that
is superior
and sustainable it's not just for
entrepreneurs
it's really for anyone who wants to
learn
how to identify and solve problems
effectively
really successful boot campers are
willing to immerse themselves in the
collaborative experience
and do so with energy each of our
cohorts
has people from anywhere from 30 to 60
different countries
we really think about selecting our
future members
for this innovation community that we're
helping to build
the bootcamp community is this place
where amazing people
around the world that really want to
change things that want to grow that are
ambitious
meet other people that are doing the
same things mit bootcamps
is not just about meeting your potential
it's about expanding it